vous entendez
certains parlent de ça comme le prochain
scandale sanitaire attention aux
téléphones portables
alors que le téléphone portable débarque
dans nos vies au début des années 80 il
va littéralement révolutionné le monde
un téléphone plus grand qu'une
télécommande du téléviseur c'est
fabuleux
et c'est pour demain cet objet
d'addiction et d'adoration utile bon
pour notre santé
non à l'irradiation forcé que
savons-nous du réel impact de ce petit
boîtier rempli de technologie
la prénom c'est une fuite en avant
technologique l'arrivée de la
saint-gilles va-t-elle sonner la fin de
la partie où le début d'une nouvelle ère
on pourra télécharger infiniment moins
d'une seconde ce soir nous recevrons le
médecin marc arazi auteur du livre gates
il va tout nous dire sur les dangers de
nos smartphones
kharazi iphone gates ou surexposées tous
trompés tous mise en danger par nos
portables
et là on va apprendre les trucs de fou
est ce que le port kabou fait peur vous
retourne la table et ouais vous êtes en
étendant oise le portable on va pas se
mentir c'est déjà 95 % des ruptures un
méchant rigaud et qu'elle loue sms les
poteaux le fc metz ouvert quant à ben
affleck prends ton portable et pourtant
on nous tue fermi kg a décollé quand à
moi de faire une photo boyer ça suffit
maintenant y'a plus de vos tombes lit
connais ça il paraît que la revanche de
castaldi il ya quelqu'un qu'il y aura un
message alors au sol sur le four à la
maison je vous appellerai l atb qui le
four ça veut dire qu'il ya un poulet qui
se voyait le message vient à la maison
créditeurs il avait vu des gens et au
restaurant les femmes ou les hommes qui
mettent le téléphone comme ça dans ce
sens là pour pas qu'on sache qu'ils
appellent non mais ça aussi ça aussi
c'est parce que pour pas qu'on nous
dérange moi c'est moi comme je le fais
ça dès que vous m'appelez je retourne
merci d'être avec nous en tout cas marc
arazi et c'est vrai qu'on a plein
d'autres choses bien plus angoissante
que ce qu'on vient de dire là c'était
plutôt drôle voilà enfin plutôt
sympathique surtout des chemins vous dit
tout sur exposé tous trompés tous mis en
danger par nos portables
est-ce que la situation est inquiétante
et qu'est ce que voulait dire par là oui
la situation est inquiétante
aucun téléphone portable aujourd'hui qui
est vendu en france en europe ou dans le
monde mais n'est sûr pour la santé
humaine
et le pire c'est que en fait depuis 30
ans
cette situation était encore bien pire
avant c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui dans
ce livre de 400 pages
j'explique de manière extrêmement
argumenté détaillé finalement toutes les
révélations qu'on a pu avoir et qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'affirmer
affirmations on a tous été surexposés
tous trompés par les fabricants et tous
mis en danger et d'une certaine façon et
je veux vraiment rendre hommage à notre
éditeur florent massot parce que ce
livre c'est une bombe
et on ne voulait pas qu'il sorte non
c'est même pas ça c'est que c'est c'est
tellement une bombe et on a été
énormément censure et d'ailleurs c'est
la première fois que je viens sera prête
aux télés ne sais pas si vous voyez
c'est un dollar
votre votre rédacteur en chef m'a appelé
je l'écoutais c'est quand même
incroyable que sur un sujet de santé
publique
soit vous cyril hanouna et c'est tout à
votre honneur que nous fassions
découvrir en france et voit alors non
seulement aux cantons étaient programmés
les reportages se passait pas quand on
était invité en plateau ou en août et
programmait voilà donc c'est normal
si vous êtes de vialer sur la chaîne tf1
s'ébruiter c'est oui mais voilà donc
forcément d'un groupe tf1 vous n'allez
pas faire beaucoup de télé un oui mais
alors si si si on commence par là 60%
des principaux médias aujourd'hui
non mais c'est pas que ça qu'orange soit
ce que vous avez à faire c'est faire
c'est vous avez free bien sûr et si on
prend cet exemple là prenons l'exemple
du monde
le monde qui est quand même la référence
parmi les journaux eh bien il ya eu un
article en décembre 2016 le terrain
fonnier d'ailleurs avez vous dire
pourquoi le monde et on va pas se mentir
le patron de free n'a elle pas un conte
du monde ils vont pas et vont pas se
tirer une balle dans le pied
si l'or est allé là il ya quand même la
responsabilité journalistique des joue
alice qui compterait des maîtres doivent
imposer un certain nombre de sujets or
tout ce qui concerne la téléphonie
mobile aujourd'hui c'est un sujet qui en
particulier de fonnier ne passe pas au
sein du move alors je vous dis docteur
ans marc arazi alors moi je pense vous
allez voir ce qui va nous dire ce soir
le docteur est ce qui arrive avec le
téléphone portable
je ne suis même pas sûr que même si les
gens ont extrêmement peur ils vont
arrêter de téléphoner ou ils vont moins
consommer et oui pour moi rennais
l'époque tous les dérange parce que
c'est mort je vous dis franchement je
pense que personne ne peut se passer de
son téléphone portable alors il ya
peut-être de trois astuces 1 qui peuvent
voilà éviter de notre petite chose mais
au niveau des appels au niveau d'un 2d
des réseaux sociaux tout ça je peux vous
dire que ça bougera pas alors je peux
moins centralisée tromper comme parce
que bon on a un autre exemple que moi je
trouve assez ses correspondants c'est la
question de la voiture et la ceinture de
cl vous souvenez
il ya une centaine d'années pour entrer
dans la voiture personnes 5 chez moi
même pas des enfants ne seraient pas des
bébés
donc en gros qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a
eu des pouvoirs publics ont dit bon là
ça suffit le nombre de morts mais qui
ont pris la responsabilité de faire des
grandes campagnes de sensibilisation et
on a changé donc je veux vraiment vous
dire qu'on peut changer mais on peut
peut-être l'envié du jeu marc a animé
une ceinture de sécurité pas pareil las
il faut revoir tous les appareils et
interdire aux gens de téléphoner il ya
tellement d'enjeux financiers je pense
que vous allez confrontée comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure à huile de
rien un lobbying qui va faire que ça
passera pas alors le point central de
votre livre c'est les téléphones
seraient dangereux pour notre santé
c'est ce car c'est ça qui intéresse nos
téléspectateurs un ring aujourd'hui
hausse des cancers du cerveau notamment
est-ce qu'on s'a on l'a vraiment vu
parce que c'est vraiment la question que
se posent nos téléspectateurs et qu'on
retrouve dans le livre à hausse des
cancers alors clairement aujourd'hui
quand on parle de ça la la la fox qu'il
passe dans tous les journaux c'est de
dire il n'y a pas d'augmentation des
cancers d'ailleurs je regrettais
d'ailleurs que le docteur michel cymes
qu'elle a des médecins les plus écoutées
les français sur rtl disait exactement
sa deuxième année 30 n'y a pas
d'augmentation et préfère et bien c'est
parfaitement fou peut savoir
en iran la griotte deux des trente
dernières années et là on sait ce que
c'est c'est santé publiquement c'est
notre agence sanitaire qui dans les
statistiques
fin 2010 elle a montré qu'il y avait une
multiplication par quatre et plus par
des cancers les plus graves
c'est à dire les glioblastomes et quand
on parle d'un glioblastome pas là pour
ceux qui ne savent pas la durée de vie
ces quelques mois et la mortalité s'est
quasiment et ça multiplie par quatre et
donc si vous voulez pour vous donner des
chiffres parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
chiffres en ce moment ça représente 50
mille morts rien qu'en france soit les
vingt dernières années et je ne parle
que des cancers les plus graves
je ne parle pas des guillaume je ne
parle pas des nourrit nombre de
l'acoustique qui etc etc alors que ça
venait voir il ya d'autres problèmes
avec le téléphone aux siens on va
regarder juste qu'on a on va passer à la
dernière partie de touche pas au poste
et on va regarder le témoignage de gira
regard des dernières parties
on a des témoignages de girard un homme
victime d'un cancer du cerveau
suite à l'utilisation régulière d'un
téléphone portable à son travail
alors ça regardez vraiment ce témoignage
parce qu'à chaque fois l'hymne de rien
docteur on sait pas on se dit est ce
qu'il aurait eu son compte son cancer du
cerveau sans le téléphone ou pas c'est
un petit peu sur ça que joue aussi
certaines personnes et 10 voilà toutes
les façons c'est pas dû au téléphone il
aurait eu quoi qu'il arrive on va voir
le témoignage quand girard du shass
thoniers nous reçoit il lutte contre son
cancer depuis plus d'un an
retraités d'atos cet ingénieur
informatique a passé plus de trente ans
dans l'entreprise
je faisais du support aux clients donc
pour ça se faisait par téléphone l'un
téléphone filaire non non non un
smartphone
le téléphone vous l'aviez collé à
l'oreille bah je l'avais collé à
l'oreille
oui c'est vrai que ça chauffait chauffer
un peu c'est normal nous avons réussi à
identifier les locaux dans lesquels
gérard du shass tony a travaillé juste
en face de l'antenne relais
voilà alors vous dites donc hausse des
cancers se ce monsieur c'est sûr que
c'est à cause de ça mais ce qu'il faut
c'est entendre ce que disent santé
publique france parce que là bon il ya
ces témoignages et baignant dans
l'excellent documentaire qui est en
replay sur france 2 2 complément
d'enquêté
vraiment il faut regarder ce
documentaire la santé publique france 10
dans les dents les conclusions
finalement qu' il y a un lien possible
avec la cancérogénicité des ondes des
téléphones portables et c'est par marca
rasé qui le dit mais c'est santé les
souliers pour comprendre il paraît qu'il
ya des problèmes cardiaques aussi voilà
en l'occurrence on a eu mais dans
l'actualité récente
la question des gens qui sont cardiaque
ou qui portent des pacemakers et alors
là c'est ça s'est focalisée sur l'iphone
12 et d'apple et tout d'un coup à apple
a dû faire entre guillemets à mea culpa
en expliquant qu' il ne pouvait y avoir
un problème de dysfonctionnement du pays
explique heures à vous imaginez bien que
quand j'ai appelé ce n'est qu'un
dysfonctionnement
c'est grave et juste pour préciser il ya
à peu près 350 mille francs
c'est qu'ils ont à minima des pacemakers
donc ce sujet là aujourd'hui il devrait
être dans la formation au grand public
on devrait être dur est passé et aux
informations télévisées
ça ne l'est pas alors et l'électro
hypersensibilité c'est quoi l'électro et
persiste alors ça c'est aussi une des
conséquences de la surexposition aux
autres c'est à dire que vous avez alors
selon là encore les chiffres de notre
agence sanitaire princesse agent
sanitaire et environnementale faut pas
les chiffres de marquer mais il ya un
rapport qui a été fait en 2018 et qui
monte qui a plus de trois millions trois
millions de personnes concernées par
exposé sensibilité et quand je dis le 3
millions c'est pas des doux dingues ça
concerne maintenant tous les genres et
société on en connaît tous autour de
nous ce soit d'ailleurs des journalistes
at elle des présentateurs des avocats
des médecins des infirmiers chauffeur de
bus à tout le monde et en gros vous avez
des gens qui ont à voir des signes
signaux faibles comme des motets des
acouphènes des vertiges des rougeurs et
puis la pire des situations c'est à dire
des gens qui sont totalement
désociabilisés parce qu'ils ne peuvent
plus vivre sans là où il ya des ombres à
la d'accord il ya un autre truc qui
serait néfaste et là je dis je croyais
pas moi je pensais que c'était bien
c'est les écouteurs alors peut-être
peut-être avant de parler des écouteurs
dire un mot sur les questions sanitaires
liés à la fertilité
parce que on téléphone portable je suis
et ça ça ne devrait pas compromettre
voilà deux surtout le premier message
qu'on va pas c'est que vous allez rouler
hier la jeunesse le relayer
régulièrement
ne mettez plus votre téléphone dans la
poche que j'ai vu à la maison tournoi
jeu devant la grille derrière
en gros il faut complètement arrêté de
mike téléphone au contact du corps et au
contact de l'oreille bon et ça
aujourd'hui il ya encore une étude
indienne qui est sorti cette semaine
elle qui faisait une analyse des études
et qui montre qu'il ya un problème
d'infertilité masculine
le problème l'arrêt manga cause du
téléphone à cause des téléphones
portables donc c'est aussi ce sujet là
ben oui parce qu'il ya des études on
n'en parle pas mais c'est parce qu'on
n'en parle pas que ça n'existe pas bien
sûr c'est nicolas non moi j'ai eu le cas
d'un ami qu'il va
un cancer des testicules mais les
médecins ont commencé à dire que c'était
dû au portable
mais d'ailleurs on lui a demandé même de
le plus maintenant dans la poche puisque
c'était à droite
l'accord et demi à gauche il a eu la
gauche non après il ya eu un espèce de
truc était classé très très vite donc
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas j'en sais
rien je suis pas en train de moi je veux
pas aller dans l'intox
maintenant c'est vrai que les enquêtes
elles vont jamais au bout bien sûr il ya
souvent des cas c'est vrai que le cancer
du cerveau on en parle beaucoup chez les
jeunes mais met en garde l'impression
qu'il ya un lobby qui fait qu'il faut
pas que ça sorte parce que au-delà du
lot même les grands mais si vous avez
comme des grands professeur en
cancérologie qui travaillent dessus qui
de temps en temps en parle mais on sent
que ça va pas très loin donc que je veux
bien croire qu'il ya un lobby mais il
s'entraîne une responsabilité en tant
que médecin alors oui mais justement
alors les écouteurs aussi ses katas
alors là le lacet pas marc arazi non
plus et département santé californien
marc arazi qui disent ah non c'est le
département d'état c'est ce que je leur
laisse le relais et puis vous le relire
et ensuite de dire qu'il ne faut plus
garder des écouteurs quand vous écoutez
de la musique ou caen pour regarder un
film ou un espace pour simplifier
alors si on voit plein la joie le
spectateur est que les écouteurs la
table le corno terminée voilà on goûte à
tout le cordon filaire à vab véhicules
et londres mais pas le concentré au
niveau de l'oreille sur le cordon alors
donc alors s'il ya une solution
1 que les simples en fait c'est d'avoir
des des des kits mains libres
hertz ou ben d'accord rco mer et sur le
ring mais en fait c'est très simple
c'est que vous avez deux les l'oseille
et dans le cordon est en fait c'est
terre n'étant pas conducteur mais mais
le fils en tout cas il va ramener des
ont dix ans en raison pas le fait quand
vous avez un kit en gros vous d'utiliser
un kit mains-libres classique et c'est
là encore c'est une hérésie parce que ça
va participer à augmenter votre
exposition alors ça veut dire qu'il faut
repenser tout le monde du travail parce
que nous dans les open space pour pas
que les autres en temps on est obligé
d'avoir le casque je ne m'étais pas
vouloir de la revue
[Rires]
bah ouais ouais ouais kurt le dérégler
ah ben voilà merci en tout cas merci
pour votre témoignage d'isabelle juge
marc arazi quand on lit vos clips aussi
alors là et ça je sais que ça intéresse
tout le monde
on parle de la 5g un oui est ce que la
5g et plus dangereuse parce que la 5g
tout le monde en parle à 5 g maintenant
il responsable de tout alors est-ce que
la 5 g/l et elle est dangereuse
oui mais elles continuent elles
dangereuses que vous allez la 4g l'était
la 3g n'est la 2g en fait parce que ce
qui est problématique c'est que la
cinquième a augmenté le niveau de
manière significative mais le pire si
vous voulez c'est que les on ne sait
même pas encore mesurer la qualité des
téléphones portables parce qu'il ya les
bancs d'essai et les normes pour mesurer
je vais pas rentrer dans des dossiers
dans l'électrotechnique mais en gros on
ne sait pas mesurer le niveau de 7
nouveaux téléphones s'achever et dernier
point là dessus c'est que vous savez que
l'état empoché 3 milliards récemment en
vendant les fréquences aux opérateurs
mais elle l'a fait avant même d'avoir la
position officielle de notre agence
sanitaire qui nous rendra son rapport
qu'en juin 2020 2021 donc la question
qu'on peut poser c'est est ce qu'on va
rembourser à l'iran les opérateurs moi
je crois pas alors justement en parlant
là des téléphones des opérateurs tout ça
est ce qu'il ya un téléphone qui est sûr
pour nos téléspectateurs est ce qu'il ya
une marque ou un téléphone ou un
smartphone ou vous dites c'est sûr il
paraît que non non ce que j'ai vu mon
retour n'a pas alors malheureusement non
non bien par téléphone sur le le le
c'est encore plus grave que ça c'est que
notre agence sanitaire
donc il faut lire les livres mais en
gros on va forcer l'agent sociales et
des fréquences à donner les résultats
des rapports de tests qui étaient gardés
secrets et on se rend compte si vous
voulez que on a tous ces faits soient
exposées de manière va hyper importante
je me suis perdu on voulait me reposer
la question c'est est-ce que les
téléphones sur au moins ma rue et dont
ils ont la foi n'est plus si vous voulez
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que l'ancien ce
qu'est ce qu'elle a demandé elle a
demandé à ce qu'on retire entendait bien
on retire ou qu'on mette à jour tous les
téléphones portables vendus avant jeu
2017 il ya le gouvernement s'était
engagé à ce qu' il ya une table ronde
avec les industriels et cette table
ronde débat n'a pas eu lieu
et aujourd'hui yard évidemment il ya la
question du coût vide mais en gros les
le gouvernement finalement privilégié
aujourd'hui les intérêts des industriels
par rapport à notre santé ce que vous
dites c'est ce que vous dites dans le
dock libre alors il parait vous dit
également que voilà tout au long de
votre livre vous expliquez avoir tenté
d'alerter les autorités publiques et les
médias en vain ce sujet a même été
classée quatrième des sujets les plus
censuré aux états unis en 2010 huit mois
a pour finir avec vous marque
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
conseils quand même pour assurer un peu
nos téléspectateurs des solutions pour
limiter la dangerosité du téléphone
quels conseils vous donneriez et qu'est
ce qu'on peut vivre sainement avec un
avec un smartphone ou pas du tout alors
il s'est coincé lors des concerts
concerne mon propos était de dire on va
continuer téléphone portable vous avez
rêvé sûr mais par contre on va changer
les utilisations et on va faire en sorte
de plus les garder au contact du corps
donc étant dit ça par exemple quand on
le pose alors est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
le met a sur sa table juste à côté non
pas la dent mais est allé quand vous
êtes au bureau vous le mettez sur la
table quand vous êtes chez vous vous le
posez l'homme est même passé doré
collier à table à côté ça va ça alors
oui parce que en gros c'est quoi ta mère
voilà c'est le contact est en partie une
marianne vient la question des enfants
aujourd'hui il va falloir avoir une
vigilance vraiment accru et là je vois
qu'on a fait don de téléspectateurs sur
la question des enfants pas que il y en
a d'autres qui nous regardent si on
arrive c'est très bien qu'elle soit là
et la porte on contacte pas on met plus
le téléphone à l'oreille d'accord à 100
et on fait attention on l'utilisé haut
parleurs quand on peut le faire dans
tout bon d'accord on est en open space
par exemple on est on est bien protégé
mais dans la poche et il ya 20 ans
arrive au contact parce que les gens
comprennent bien que quand on était son
téléphone ben on l'a on a d emblée n'ont
pas compris que quand le téléphone était
dans la poche et continuer à fonctionner
ça et sur le mode avion alors comme
disait en mode avion on va bien
évidemment avoir beaucoup moins d'avoir
un avenant et les clairs
jusqu'à un point par exemple est-ce que
ça c'est quelque chose que tout le monde
vit en ile-de-france et dans beaucoup de
villes c'est la question des transports
en commun évident que quand vous êtes
dans le métro dans le rer
ouais vous êtes vraiment dans la pire
situation sert que les zombies vont
prendre assez important c'est le niveau
d'exposition va augmenter de manière
très très important et vous devez alors
à la vraiment être encore plus vigilant
mais de téléphone dans un cercle dans un
sac à dos dans une poche extérieure afin
d'éviter de téléphoner les pires
conditions
c'est quand vous êtes en déplacement en
sous sol non finalement dans les dents
des mauvaises conditions de réception
oui nicolas nord il ya quand même une
chose où j'entends quand même de plus en
plus de médecins qui en parlent à 2 1 et
un de son portable et surtout pas le
brancher à côté de votre lit arrive même
pas à côté du corps mais plutôt de le
mettre dans une autre pièce square
poisson il ya des ondes
vraisemblablement il ya quand même
beaucoup dans d'aussi quand il est en
charge
ouais mais remédier à tour il ya une
raison encore c'est quoi qui est
complémentaire à celle que vous évoquez
c'est la question des des alertes en
mots on a besoin le sommeil ces
réparateurs on en a c'est indispensable
pour nous pour la qualité de notre vie
au quotidien alors là dans la journée
imaginez que vous êtes réveillé par dix
alerte vous croyez le téléphone que vous
répondiez à des mails des sms
en fait le rôle réparateur du sommeil
n'existe plus n'existe plus et donc très
rapide des castes à dix après la
baignade et à des problèmes de santé
alors oui très vite on m'appelle je
m'intéresse à lutter alors des questions
intéressantes donc c'est pas vous les 8
premières plaintes au pénal c'était en
2010 neuf on en est où alors ils se
pressent sur rfm voilà j'ai lu ça c'est
quoi l'histoire oui est ce qu'il ya des
coqs qui existe vraiment éclairé du
gazon de empêche de passer la parole ou
est ce que c'est une légende où ils
assez bien entendu notre métier
on a une chance dans ce scandale c'est
que les solutions de pour qu'on sorte
tous avec la meilleure santé possible
elles sont simples en fait on a besoin
de changer des usages sur tout contact
c'est le travail simplifié et quand vous
regardez les films avec les gens qui
fumaient dans et dans tout l'est dans
tous les films dans tout l'est dans
toutes les séries etc
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez vous
avez la même chose les gens les bêtes le
téléphone dans la poche il mégane
téléphone alors elle vous n'aurez plus à
n'y a pas tellement les années où vous
dirais tu n'as pas ta moi qui me pose
une question intéressante plus
intéressante que vous
c'est jérôme c qui me dit est ce que
vous avez un téléphone vous oui bien sûr
et alors comment il se voulait pas le
laisser
qu'est ce que c'est que ça il est en
mode avion
voilà énorme attention sinon jamais ça
jamais mais je joue la transparence
1 c'est en l'occurrence ça arrive
extrêmement je peux jamais vous avez
raison d'ailleurs c'est jean-marc
attention mais je prie je suis abonné à
long terme et pas qu'à ça mais je veux
vraiment redire pourra le vérifier
propose même qu on le vérifie demande à
casal d'ivoire
sur le côté
non mais j'ai un contrôleur castaldi qui
alors quoi vérifier que j'étais bien en
mode et leighlin mois on avait plusieurs
fois demandé pourquoi est-ce que je ne
réponds jamais quand on m'appelle c'est
vrai vous êtes posé la question
moi je lui ai demandé trois mois moi ok
en fait j'ai très peur raison des mon
téléphone quand je n'appelle pas
quelqu'un est toujours un mot d'ordre
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas me joindre
j'ai très très peur des ondes parce que
je sais que les dégâts que ça peut faire
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai toujours une
petite manif mais pas la saveur mais
j'aimerais juste à dire haut et fort que
ça et j'aimerais juste dire aux jeunes
faut pas dormir avec le téléphone à côté
où je connais des gens ils dorment avec
le truc sous location et ensuite scellé
mal de tête et ensuite c'est les tumeurs
chez moi je sais ce que je fais moi
j'allais vous donner un bon point parce
que jouer votre téléphone est posée sur
un jour ouais et donc ça serait bien
non mais par contre c'est vrai qu'il
faut changer des habitudes parce que là
dormir c'est très important avait
compris et que et là aussi on a des
études qui centrait de la fête sur les
troubles cognitifs est reparti et vous
qui parlez aussi l'annoncé toujours 26
accords non mais j'ai essayé et ça c'est
très important dans tout le long du
livre de donner les références pour que
les gens comprennent bien que c'est pas
la position d'un médecin par la position
des auteurs d'exactions de vous
expliquer dernière chose que neuf
téléphones testés sur 10 dépassé les
limites réglementaires
voilà des ondes tout ça donc neuf
téléphones sur 10 et c'est quoi le
dernier bon vin versés tous les revenus
qu'ils demanderont pourquoi on parle de
fonnier parce que je n'avais pas qu'on
en oublie ça c'est comme le disait vous
avez une situation où des fabricants on
voit là les utiliser des téléphones pour
porte à préparer pour les explications
et pire encore des logiciels espions
autorités intégré au téléphone pour
pouvoir voir quand il était en situation
de contrôle par les rares contrôle et
modifier le niveau de das du téléphone
donc j'aime mieux vous dire que cette
affaire-là jeu uniquement
on répondra
votre question à elle est loin d'être
aisée puisque ce sera mon dernier mot
cette semaine vous avez un grand procès
aux états unis avec les organisations
américaines parce que le foot gay il a
fait son a fait son coming deux aux
états unis et en gros l'abs avec déjà
des grandes actions collectives un peu
partout aux états-unis au canada contre
apple contre samsung et chez cette
semaine vous aviez une action contre le
régulateur américain
mais la lcc et donc ses prix très très
sérieusement cette affaire la chaux ce
sera on le dit comme ça fang et ça sera
dix fois le diesel guesdon vous allez en
entendre parler
ça c'est sûr matin midi et soir et vous
pouvez vous honorez monsieur hanouna
madame je me sente gate docteur marc
arazi merci